[Music]
an event in downtown Las Vegas
celebrating Asian American Pacific
Islanders culture and Community 8 news
now reporter Brian will is down there
catch an island fever Brian how's it
going down there
yeah Aloha Sasha we're here at the
Mahalo event and you can take a look at
what's going on behind me so much
happening here more than 20 vendors
highlighting Hawaiian Cuisine Art goods
and you can even hear the good music
happening in the background here now if
you come down to the event tonight you
can see prominent Hawaiian voices from
the community representing Aloha Spirit
including performers like Kenny King
local chefs and eateries like stop drop
and roll and of course that fresh shaved
ice Island Fair it's a way for the
public and the Asian Pacific Islanders
Community to come together
well one it brings a bunch of foot
traffic down to the park for the small
business within the park but also
supports the smaller businesses like
vendors and I mean from the type of
products or maybe the type of food that
we don't have within the park
celebrating like community and cultural
events
[Music]
now they plan to have another event this
fall and if you happen to miss tonight's
event you can always come here tomorrow
for their first ever Farmers Market
they're having here at Container Park
and of course entry to the park is free
so if you have time you can still make
it out this event that's going on until
eight I'm gonna get the man behind the
camera here Mark some shaved ice in
downtown Las Vegas primewell 8 News Now